مشاهدينا خطط الاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم
اوكرانيا بالسلاح باتت تواجه معضله بسبب
مطالب قدمتها فرنسا في اجتماع للاتحاد في
بروكسيل فرنسا مشاهدينا وبحسب تقرير
لصحيفه تيجراف البريطانيه متهمه بتاخير
خطه الاتحاد الاوروبي البالغه ملياري يورو
لتجديد مخزون قذائف المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
مصادر اوروبيه قالت ان باريس تريد ضمانات
بان صفقه هذه الاسلحه التي تبلغ مليارين
يورو لشراي اسلحه بشكل مشترك ستفيد فقط
الشركات الموجوده في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد يجري حاليا محادثات لشراء مليون
قذيفه مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملم لدعم
اوكرانيا وايضا لملء مستودعات الاسلحه
الاوروبيه المستنفذه وحتى الان لم تزود
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اوكرانيا الا ب
30000 قذيفه مدفعيه من هذا العيار كما سدد
الاتحاد لل الاعضاء
450 مليون يورو مقابل التبرعات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا وبواقع يورو فاصل 28 عن كل
قذيفه متبرع بها ميدانيا على الارض تطلق
القوات الاوكرانيه ما يقدر بنحو سته الاف
طلقه مدفعيه كل يوم وفقا للمخابرات
الغربيه بينما قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
في اجتماع مع نظرائه الاوروبيين ان
اوكرانيا تحتاج لمئه الف طلقه مدفعيه
شهريا لتخفيف النقص في ساحه المعركه وفي
الجهه المقابله روسيا تطلق 20,000 قذيفه
في اليوم وهي ذات الكميه التي يصنعها
المنتجون الاوروبيون